A new study finds that healthy foods are three
times more expensive than unhealthy foods.
You know what, screw this, I’m going to
McDonalds.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and I dunno
about you guys, but one of the excuses people
always love to give for eating like crap,
is that it’s more expensive to eat healthy
than it is to eat unhealthy.
And naturally, I assumed it was just that
- an excuse.
But apparently, it’s actually true - and
according to a new study out of the UK, healthy
food is three times more expensive per calories,
than less healthy foods.
Who knew?
This was a study published recently in PLOS
One, that tracked the prices of 94 key food
and beverage items from 2002 to 2012.
Now to clarify, these are foods you would
find at any supermarket - so we’re not talking
about McDonalds or Taco Bell, which are definitely
more expensive.
These are foods specifically used by the UK’s
Office of National Statistics, to measure
the rate of inflation year over year.
Researchers then matched the prices of those
foods, with their caloric content - and classified
them as either healthy or unhealthy, based
on their nutritional value.
What they found, is that not only have the
prices of food risen in the UK faster than
the price of other goods, healthy foods specifically
have experienced a much sharper price hike
in recent years: about $2.95 for every thousand
calories, compared to unhealthy foods which
have only risen $1.17 in the same amount of
time.
So each year, healthy foods are getting progressively
more expensive.
And studies from other high-income nations
have found similar results.
Obviously, for countries with obesity epidemics,
like the US and especially the UK, where obesity
is one of the leading causes of preventable
deaths, it’s important that people realize
the effects of eating unhealthily.
According to the National Health Service,
diet-related health problems cost an estimated
9 trillion dollars every year.
But for households that are straddling the
poverty line, it can be difficult to convince
people that spending more money now on eating
healthy, will actually pay off in the long
run.
So the researchers in this study, are calling
on public health officials to address the
rising prices of healthy foods, in hopes that
they’ll regulate them - and provide subsidies
to those in need - for the good of the nation’s
health.
What do you guys think?
Especially those of you on a tight budget
- does the price of food influence how healthy
you eat?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below - and as always, thank you guys for
watching!